[Music]
meghan trainor and Darryl separa are
engaged yeah
he's changed my entire life the couple
who have been together for over a year
announced the exciting news to Instagram
on Megan's 24th birthday
both posting this video of the sweet
proposal Friday night Megan wrote I said
yes for my 24th birthday the love of my
life made all of my dreams come true he
proposed to me under a tunnel of
beautiful Christmas lights while Darryl
captioned the video in part happy
birthday to my soulmate thank you for
changing my life forever and thank you
for saying yes
et spoke with the me to singer earlier
this month
where she gushed over how her man has
changed her life and outlook on fitness
if he cooks for me and taught me how to
cook and he taught me like how you can
feel better if you eat healthier and
exercise and even mentally like I cuz
after my second surgery I went into this
kind of dark place and he was like want
to work out and I was like no but okay
and now I love it I'm obsessed with it
and I've never felt better
[Music]
you